es gibt ein statement von wladimir putin
das war als nächstes anhören wollen das
ist natürlich auch als reaktion zu
verstehen auf die neue strategie der
nato auf die nato-erweiterung und eben
auch auf das aufstocken der schnellen
eingreiftruppe
mit nico stunde darüber wie spa wir
haben kein problem damit dass finnland
und schweden nato-mitglieder werden wenn
sie wollen dann bitte schön aber sie
sollten klar verstehen das ist für sie
vorher keine bedrohung gegen die kurven
dort jetzt aber nato truppen stationiert
werden und infrastruktur eingerichtet
wird dann müssen wir in gleicher weise
reagieren dieselbe bedrohungen schaffen
die von diesem gebiet für uns ausgeht
und zum studios andreas dittmers
geografen konfliktforscher ich grüße sie
herr
dittmann jetzt hört man bleibe mir putin
kann man verständnis haben in gewisser
weise für seine rolle das werde ich auch
auf draußen gefragt wenn man sagt ist
das wirklich so schwarz weiß wie es sie
auch in den medien immer dargestellt
wird was ist ihre einschätzung
ja herr schwarz weiß ist selten eine
solche konstellation und dann noch eine
konstellation die sich auf beiden seiten
in der gegenseitigen bewertung und in
der kommentierung auch ende also das
statement dass finnland und schweden
frei in ihrer entscheidung seien weil er
so ziemlich genau das gegenteil von dem
mit putin lange vorher immer gedroht hat
und stichwort rom das ist dann das
zweite in der ansprache dass also
unverhohlener geht es gar nicht man kann
sagen ihr seid bedroht oder sowie ihren
gesagt hat bisher war ihr nicht bedroht
im grunde genau das gleiche also von
daher ist es sehr schwer das einzuordnen
weil sich wie gesagt auf beiden seiten
immer auch die einstellungen ändern das
war auch auf der ukrainischen seite in
bezug auf wem gehört der don bosco ihm
gehört die gründer hat es auch mehrfach
gewechselt und putin ist jetzt natürlich
in einer situation die er vorher nicht
erwartet hatte und die er seit 24
februar auch seinerseits mehrfach ändern
muss was dabei gleichgeblieben ist als
kontinuum ist die ist die drohung
richtung nato richtung westen das ist
das was nach wie vor dabei bleibt aber
es sind so viele unwägbarkeiten
inzwischen geschehen die auch nicht
vorher gesehen oder berechnet haben kann
und dazu zählte dann der vielleicht noch
größere aus russischer sicht größere als
ein militärisches nicht so schnell
voranschreiten in der ukraine wie
geplant war und das ist dann die de
facto nord ost erweiterung der nato das
ist schon ein herber schlag das genaue
gegenteil war der fall das schwächeln
der nato auf unterschiedlichen gebieten
war eigentlich der langzeit plan dazu
gehört das kuscheln mit der türkei dazu
gehört das ja auch eigentlich
verlässliche partner im westen hatte in
seinem langzeit plan sowohl die eu als
auch die nato zu destabilisieren aus
seiner sicht wird irgendwann in seine
liste der selbst gemachten fehler
sicherlich auch aufgenommen werden
müssen der zeitpunkt des angriffs auf
die ukraine hätte er noch 14 tage
gewartet wäre eine seiner wichtigsten in
anführungszeichen mitspieler in europa
lippen vielleicht mit einem viel
besseren wahlergebnis aus der
französischen waren heraus gehe um die
war ja eine der wichtigen unterstützer
und sie hat viele stimmen gekostet das
da dieses bild wie sie hand schütteln
mit putin unterwegs war das hat die
französische rechte um le pen sehr
schwach gemacht
makro letztendlich gewinnen lassen und
wäre aber le pen eine nummer geworden
mit der man in frankreich brechen muss
dann hätte er auf zwei weiteren
nebenkriegsschauplätzen gewonnen nämlich
einerseits eine eu skeptikerin erster
stunde und eine die auch sagte dass sie
der nato gegenüber sehr kritisch
eingestellt ist eigentlich sogar
frankreich aus der nato heraus haben
wollte und dieses 14 tage nicht warten
das hat sie dann stimmen gekostet und
mit ihm auch einen wichtigen de
stabilisierungsfaktor in europa wir
wollen mal live nach madrid schon
schauen wir erwarten jetzt gleich die
unterzeichnungszeremonie der
verpflichtungserklärung das natürlich
ein großer akt aus sicht von putin ein
großer affront weil die nato sich doch
sehr selbstbewusst und sehr verstärkend
als derzeit 30 mitglieder starkes
bündnis zeigt es hat russland ausgemacht
als großen strategischen feind aber auch
china hat einen abbekommen sage ich mal
und wird auch als nicht ganz
ordnung
dargestellt und auch als werte gegner
und natürlich auch als militärischer
geht wir haben hier die staats und
regierungschefs und natürlich das
diplomatische korps was daneben dahinter
steht was natürlich ständig im austausch
ist und diese gespräche in präsenz die
jetzt stattfinden wo auch bundeskanzler
olaf scholz sagte die sind so
unglaublich nötig gewesen in elm kurz
rasch auch vielleicht mal auf einem
spaziergang über die grüne wiese den
kopf klar zu bekommen und sich noch mal
zu vergewissern welche großen ziele
wollen wir eigentlich angreifen damit
wir uns nicht im klein-klein einer
vielleicht irgendwo in die ecke gefahren
in diplomatie verkämpfen das ist glaube
ich auch ein zeichen dass jetzt von
madrid aus gehen soll und dass in
wenigen minuten in der
verpflichtungserklärung auch ratifiziert
werden wird andreas dittmann ist bei uns
im studio ist das wirklich ein
historisches treffen wie es so oft heißt
das hat den eindruck er habe mit dem
wort historisch muss man sehr vorsichtig
umgehen da waren wir in den letzten
monaten ist es mehrfach benutzt worden
aber das ist jetzt schon so also seit 30
jahren hat es keine wesentlichen
mitglieder veränderungen in der nato
geben der eine oder andere bröckelte der
nächste hat wieder die nato als hirntot
bezeichnet aber es blieb territorial in
der familie der nato-mitglieder
eigentlich stabil und insofern ist nach
30 jahren darf man dann das wort
historisch verwenden vor allen dingen
weil es ja auch zwei länder betrifft die
bisher ganz bewusst auf ihre neutralität
wert gelegt haben das immer wieder
betont haben das gilt ganz besonders für
schweden das 200 jahre jetzt immer
vorgibt komplett neutral gewesen zu sein
wie das neutralen wirklich während der
zeit des zweiten weltkrieges waren
darüber streiten sich noch die
historiker und gilt in abgeschwächtem es
dann auch für finnland also dass es
schon historisch diese nord ost
erweiterung die außer der dem addieren
von zwei zusätzlichen nato-ländern auch
zwei andere wichtige parameter mit denen
diskussion bringt das eine ist die
verlängerung der direkten grenze
zwischen russland und nato durch die
finnisch russische grenze und das andere
ist ein ein gewisses sicherheitsgefühl
dass diese erweiterung auf die andere
seite des baches auf die andere seite
der
ostsee für die baltischen staaten
bedeutet die von allen nato mitgliedern
sicherlich diese beiden beitrittsgesuch
am meisten begrüßen werden wurden sie
doch bisher nur so als eine art
stolperdraht für die nato interpretiert
den man nicht viel
widerstandskraft zugewiesen hätte und
das ändert sich jetzt schon komplett in
dem die ostsee mehr oder weniger fast
komplett rundherum von nato
mitgliedsländern mit bis auf zwei
ausnahmen russland selbst und dann das
kaliningrad wo sich im gebiet in unter
nato kontrolle ist und insofern ist
glaube ich hier aus den genannten drei
gründen historisch schon ein ausdruck
den man durchaus verwenden da ein mann
der historie schreibt ist ja ein
stoltenberg das sehen wir gerade rechts
im bild
macht einen guten job aus ihrer sicht
oder wird er quasi getragen also wird
sozusagen die ernte für ein nato general
sekretär im kostenlos ins haus getragen
ja auch da wir hatten ja begonnen mit
den veränderungen die die involvierten
politiker und andere akteure im lauf der
zeit im lauf der letzten vier monate
durchgemacht haben da gehört stoltenberg
sicherlich auch dazu der vorher schon
einen anderen vielleicht nicht ganz so
spannenden job an avisiert hatte und
dann sich dazu hat überreden lassen sich
wahrscheinlich auch selbst mit überredet
hat da jetzt weiter zu machen er wollte
noch in norwegen wie der chef der
notenbank gelangen schon staatschefs
nato-generalsekretär eigentlich war
geplant die das ja so lädt eine sofaecke
und situationen die nato dann war wäre
es wirklich nicht gut gewesen wenn da
jetzt der sagen wir mal der kapitän das
schiff verlassen hätte und da ist es
auch aus nato sicht
begründbaren und zu begrüßen dass er
weiter gemacht hat gut aber lieber ein
lieber würde man ja sagen wenn dann
schlechter kapitän gewesen wäre lieber
einen anderen kapitän auch wenn wenn es
sozusagen schnell vorangeht aber glauben
sie auch dass er den richtigen ton
trifft in diesen tagen in dieser
unaufdringlichkeit in dieser
nüchternheit weil es ist ja doch ein
paar beispiel russland und jetzt auch
china so zu provozieren
ja obwohl die die töne richtung china
die sind ja solche die
andere nato-mitglieder wie deutschland
zum beispiel nicht so stark anstoßen und
solche die jetzt quasi in einer art
politischen deal wenn die amerikaner so
an nato seite in europa stehen dann
wünschen sie natürlich auch dass man
verbal so ähnlich richtung china hat
sich ausdrückt wie dass die amerikaner
die hier vor ihrer näheren eigenen
haustür 20 pazifik einen konkurrenten
wittern
bis so ungefähr um den 20 februar diesen
jahres waren stoltenbergs äußerungen
relativ moderat und er gehörte auch zu
denen die auf öffentliche zumindest ein
angriffskrieg bis fast zum schluss für
weniger wahrscheinlich hielten und so
erst in den letzten vier fünf tagen vor
dem 24 02 hat sich dann auch sein ton
geändert hat ja dann durchblicken lassen
dass man das nicht mehr für ein manöver
halten könnte was da an aufmarsch und
der wille russisch-ukrainischen und
russisch ukrainischen grenze zu
verzeichnen war da hat man schon gemerkt
dass ein umdenken in der bewertung
dessen was putin sagte und der differenz
dazu was putin machte zu erkennen war
und hat da ändert sich das und auch dann
wie sie sagten der ton sind stoltenberg
aber jeweils dann sind wir neue neuen
kalten krieg oder wie welches welche
begrifflichkeit würden sie dieser zeit
im jahr 2022 jetzt geben wollen ist es
ist ja alles im werden man kann ja noch
nicht abschließend sagen das ist nun mal
die faser das lässt sich erst im
nachhinein im zu rückblick richtig
eindeutig machen aber welche worte
würden sie finden ich glaube das aus
zwei gründen der begriff
neue ost west konflikt vielleicht besser
werden denn ein kalter krieg neu zu
beginnen oder einen neuen kalten krieg
zu sehen würde ja einerseits bedeuten
dass eine heiße phase des kalten
krieges vorbei ist und das ist es ja
nicht eher klein wird weiterhin gekämpft
also natürlich sind die ideologischen
gründe die im hintergrund stehen heute
auch ganz andere als das damals eher
dass das kämpfen die konkurrenz von zwei
unterschiedlichen weltanschauungen
modellen bahn so ist es heute eher die
militärische die territoriale
einflussnahme aus putin sich die macht
über bestimmte gebiete
und wenn man ost west neue ost west
konflikt anstelle von neuer kalter krieg
sagt dann öffnet das wieder den teil zu
ihrem ersten teil ihrer frage und
erweitert den blick richtung ostasien
und daher die ja damals im alten kalten
krieg wenn man so will nicht unbedingt
direkt eingebunden waren das hat sich
dann nur auf einem kleinen regionalen
bereich konzentriert also neue kalte
krieg hängt mit zwei beinen der und neue
ost west konflikt rückschlüsse leicht
genommen kann ich nachvollziehen und
sogleich frage ich natürlich wir leben
ja in einer einer polizeit ich sage mal
in einer vielzahl zeiten wir sind
natürlich alle geschult in dieser
aristotelischen logik des rechts links
des jahn 1 des ost west denkens also in
diesem dualismus muss man nicht
eigentlich
von von einer ja noch mehr noch mehr
also weg vom ost west konflikt denken
noch her noch neuen begriff finden
dieses vielfache
unterstreicht denn auch auf dem
nato-treffen sah man ja wie stark die
hände gereicht werden von diesem klub
des westens hat er gegen den klub des
ostens kämpfte hin zu den pazifik
staaten also ist ja so eine offene
gesellschaft die sich jetzt präsentiert
ja ich bin jetzt spontan nicht in der
lage neuen begriff
das hat ja auch nicht erwarten aber die
zentren konstellation die wir deutlich
vor allen dingen war es für alle
beteiligten insbesondere für die
entscheidungsträger wäre die sich jetzt
auf die unterzeichnung aktuell
vorbereiten
eigentlich ganz gut dass der g 7 gipfel
davor war ja dass man also mit so einem
halben gefühl das nicht so ganz getragen
sein oder auch der frustration aus den
g7 statements heraus ging und sich dann
jetzt innerhalb der in anführungszeichen
familie der nato doch einheitliche
fühlt und fühlen kann und auch etwas
konkret auf den weg bringt wir haben
eben frau lamprecht im bild gesehen die
deutsche verteidigungsminister in welche
rolle kommt auf die bundeswehr zu die
muss ich ja ganz gehörig heute
ja
genau wenden denn heute dass das würde
ja auch bedeuten dass man ein anderer
ein alters
lichtbild ablegen und sich ganz neu
orientiert das ist jetzt nur eigentlich
ein stärker orientieren in bereichen in
denen man vorher sowieso aktiv war es
wird sicherlich nicht mehr möglich sein
beides zu tun sich einerseits innerhalb
der nato stärker aufzustellen und
zweitens auch international so hoch
engagiert zu zeigen wie das bisher war
also mit atalanta in der
piratenbekämpfung im roten meer
untermauern von afrika oder in mali
afghanistan ist jetzt seit dem 14 august
vergangenen jahres kein thema mehr aber
dieses spielen auf verschiedenen
auslandseinsatz plätzen wo er die
bundeswehr und durchaus ein gutes
gesamtbild hinterlassen hat jetzt in
mali sozusagen noch das rückgrat
darstellt für die un-truppen die da sind
und diejenigen die die bundeswehr erst
nach mali riefen die franzosen längst
weg sind also da ist ein
1 1 zurückziehen und konzentrieren auf
die eigentlichen nato kernaufgaben
sicherlich ein wichtiger bereich und
dann wird eine große herausforderung
hier von uns etwas rheinaufwärts in
koblenz für die verwalter und
verwalterin dort seien im heeres
beschaffungsamt die in aussicht
gestellte zeitenwende mit dem ungeheuer
vielen geld auch ausgaben mäßig auf den
weg zu bringen und dabei vielleicht auch
den einen oder anderen
verwaltungsvorgang bisschen schneller zu
machen als das bisher war also wenn die
eine milliarde putin vielleicht ein
bisschen erschreckt hat dann diejenigen
die jetzt damit umgehen müssen
vielleicht sogar noch mehr